ich habe das schlechteste Restaurant in
ganz Berlin getestet um zu schauen ob es
wirklich so schlecht ist wie im Internet
bewertet im R23 soll es deutsche Küche
und internationale Speisen geben und mit
3,2 Sternen schneidet dieses Restaurant
wirklich unterirdisch schlecht an das
Essen soll nicht gut sein Kellner
komisch Toilette dreckig und und
hoffentlich bekommen wir noch was zu
essen um die Zeit ich glaube ich bin auf
jeden Fall schon mal eine Kartoffelsuppe
Berliner Art
Kartoffelsuppe
aber
nicht und dann nehme ich noch die
Käsespätzle alkoholfrei nee
wieso wieso
ein bisschen Brot als Vorspeise
nicht so wirklich 5 von 10 aber man muss
einfach sagen läuft trotzdem finde ich
3,2 Stunden ein bisschen aber